when we look at a religion and its
development from a historical and
scholarly perspective
rather than through a theological or
apologetic lens
one of the most important aspects to
keep in mind is the historical context
in which the religion emerges
this is of course also true for the
religion of islam
the prophet muhammad on whom the islamic
religion is based basically
lived and preached in western arabia in
the 7th century
so what was the historical social
religious and intellectual context and
environment
that led to this massive event or in
more general terms what
was the religious landscape like in
pre-islamic arabia
the classic or common narrative is
pretty straightforward and simple
the arabs were polytheistic pagans who
worshipped many different gods before
the arrival of islam
after which everyone basically became
monotheistic muslims
the main source or sources that have
been used both historically and mostly
today also
in describing pre-islamic arabia has
actually been on the one part
the seerah literature or the biography
literature of the prophet muhammad
written by muslim authors a few
centuries after
his life furthermore perhaps the most
important source
that we have is the text called kitab
al-asnam
or the book of idols written by hashem
eben alkelby
in the 9th century for obvious reasons
these sources are very problematic in
several ways
they were of course written with a
specific purpose in mind
to legitimize the islamic monotheistic
tradition as triumphant or with the
backwardness of the pre-islamic arabs
in the words of the scholar ahmed
al-jalad
paganism was an established trope used
to bring into sharp relief
the distinction between islamic practice
and what came
before it goes without saying that these
accounts are
biased and polemical in nature and that
the people that are actually talked
about the
people who actually practiced the
polytheistic religions of pre-islamic
arabia
get to have no say in telling the story
about their own religious tradition
that isn't to say that everything that
abner kelby or the cedar biographers
write is inaccurate far from it actually
a lot of the information that a person
like ibn khabib gives us
is actually often confirmed by the
archaeological evidence and it's still a
very
good source to use but to get a picture
that is more balanced
nuanced and historically accurate we
need to look
elsewhere luckily for us the last few
years has seen
an absolute explosion of activity when
it comes to scholarship on
ancient arabia archaeological
excavations and
expeditions are continuously conducted
in northern arabia and
and other places as well as by amateur
archaeologists across the arabian
peninsula
that are turning up some absolutely
revolutionary findings
for example many rock inscriptions from
the ancient arabs
give us first-hand accounts of the
culture and tradition
and religion of this sort of lost
culture
and once we start to look at the new
scholarly and archaeological findings
a picture emerges that is a lot more
complicated than the
simple classical narrative that i
presented at the beginning
so with the latest scholarly research in
mind let's take a look at the
fascinating world of religion
in pre-islamic arabia
[Applause]
[Music]
late antiquity was a very vibrant period
and arabia was not
isolated from the major historical
events and happenings of the time
indeed scholars realize more and more
just how much
arabia and the arabs participated in the
wider culture of the middle east
being a major part of trade routes and
often being vassals to great empires
now talking about pre-islamic arabia
gives us pretty enormous
spans of time in which things could of
course differ and
change a lot but we're going to focus
mainly on the period very shortly before
the prophet muhammad
on the eve of islam as it is sometimes
called
the middle east at this time was
dominated by two major
empires the byzantine or eastern roman
empire
and the sassanian persian empire arabia
being basically sandwiched in between
the two
the byzantine empire at this time were
christians and the sasanian persians
generally followed the zoroastrian
religion
an important aspect to remember is that
the arabs quote unquote
were not a unified and homogenous group
of people at this time
arabia consisted of a number of
different tribes and clans whose
affiliations and traditions could differ
for example at this time were the
lachmids of north
eastern arabia who allied themselves
with the sasanian empire and were
primarily polytheistic
on the other hand there were the
razonids of northwestern arabia
who functioned as a client state to the
byzantine empire
and who were mostly christians so
already we can see a diversity here
and things get even more complicated in
general
looking at the various archaeological
evidence that we have
like rock inscriptions for example we
can conclude
that most of the inhabitants of the
arabian peninsula historically
did follow a kind of polytheism or
paganism
the details of this religious tradition
is quite obscure and
unknown but we do know a few things the
ancient arabs worshiped a number of
different deities and gods
some of these gods were associated with
a specific place
or with a specific tribe and so on there
were also
sanctuaries for different deities
located all around arabia which
worshippers could visit
many of these deities also seem to have
representations of natural phenomena or
abstract concepts
one example is the god shems which
literally means
sun the historian robert j hoyland
writes quote
loosely of course the gods represented
those forces that were important to the
lives of their devotees but beyond their
control
rain fertility health love death and so
on
by seeking the favor of the gods
typically making some votive gift
one might thereby influence these forces
we also have many other famous deities
including allat
a goddess or fertility probably similar
to and possibly even linked with
aphrodite of the greek pantheon
and the ishtar of mesopotamian mythology
a lot is one of the deities that are
mentioned the most in all of the rock
carvings that have been
found and clearly played a major role
for the ancient arabs
she is also one of the three goddesses
that are actually mentioned
in the quran itself alongside manat
and al-uzza although recent scholarships
suggest that the latter may have been
identical to a lot and simply been a
kind of
title for this goddess another central
deity appears to have been
rudow associated with the moon and
sometimes considered the father of
allah rudow was a powerful god who was
particularly associated with the region
of chaldea in southern mesopotamia
we also have baal-sami more simply baal
a deity of rain and storm whose name we
recognize from the canaanite religion as
depicted in the bible
in any case these are just a few
examples of the many different gods that
the arabs would worship
as hoyland suggested these gods could be
invoked for many different reasons
most commonly probably mundane things
like good health or to
help with various troubles in life take
for example
rock inscriptions such as these quotes
help ib with that which he desires or
o allat daughter of rudow deliver so and
so
from the year of war indeed most of the
rock carvings from ancient arabia
contains prayers like this
prayers asking the gods for protection
or security from their enemies or for
from other misfortunes as i said earlier
certain gods could be associated with a
specific tribe and act as the protector
of that tribe
while other gods would be more universal
and worshipped across the
a wider population including gods like
alat and
i have mentioned but we also find of
course regional preferences
since the tribes and the various groups
of arabia differed on
a number of accounts so we find certain
gods that are
specifically popular in southern arabia
while other gods are more popular in
northern arabia and so on it was a
diverse
religious context or environment
we should also keep in mind not only
that arabia is a large place that
contains many different
groups that differed on a number of
accounts but also
that the population of arabia could live
different lives so some people some
arabs were nomads who
moved around lived in in desert
environments and so on
while others lived in developed city
environments and
these different circumstances also of
course affected the religious
traditions and religious practices that
that the arabs would partake in
now aside from these prayers the deities
were worshiped through various different
rites
the worshippers or servants called abed
in arabic
could make offerings to the gods
probably things such as
food and so on like in many other
polytheistic traditions
like in so many other cultures of
antiquity animal sacrifice appears to
have played a major role in their
religious rights
animals often camels would be sacrificed
before major events or to aid in the
effectiveness of certain prayers for
example
as we saw earlier there were also
shrines dedicated to specific deities
located
in locations all around arabia and this
is connected to another one of the most
central and important rituals or
rights or practices of the pre-islamic
arabs
which was the pilgrimage pilgrimages
referred to as
hajj just like in the islamic equivalent
would be undertaken to a shrine at a
specific time during the yearly calendar
like an annual festival or celebration
these shrines or special places were
referred to as
haram or sanctuaries where all forms of
violence were forbidden
presumably one of these common shrines
that were visited by pilgrims was the
kaaba in mecca something that the
islamic tradition itself affirms
the classic narrative is that the kaaba
in mecca
thought by muslims to have been built by
abraham himself
served as an important site of
pilgrimage for people across arabia
and that it housed the images of many
different gods in the broader pantheon
before of course being liberated and
once again dedicated to the one
monotheistic god
by muhammad and the arrival of islam and
our information about the general
practices of pilgrimage in pre-islamic
times
seems to corroborate this story other
connections or similarities to the later
islamic tradition
can be found in the rules relating to
ritual purity
so before going on a pilgrimage or
praying to a god or really before any
kind of
religious rite the worshiper was
expected to
make ablutions and to purify himself and
wash himself
to enter a state of ritual purity in
general we find that the religion of
ancient arabia is one that is in some
ways familiar to an antique middle
eastern context
there are other beliefs and practices
that we don't have too much
information about for example and as we
have explored in a previous episode
the arabs believed in other mysterious
beings such as the
jinn ghost-like figures who would hang
around abandoned ruins and dark places
we also know of various occult practices
such as divination and techniques
involving the evil eye
poetry played a major role in the lives
of the ancient arabs and
poets were sometimes considered to be
inspired by the divine beings to recite
their verses
becoming almost like messengers for the
gods
but even in less extravagant
circumstances poetry
served an important function of
storytelling and the literary form that
held the highest
of esteem in this culture the most
famous collection of pre-islamic poetry
the mualaqat or
hanging poems is another important
source for the culture and traditions of
the arabs at this time
as well as being some of the greatest
literary achievements in the arabic
language
but so far i've only talked about
polytheism with gods like allat
and ruda and so on but as it turns out
the religious
landscape of ancient arabia was a lot
more complicated than that
and there were a lot of different
religious traditions and movements
that actually coexisted on this
peninsula especially in the last few
centuries before the arrival of islam
and this includes as we will see
various forms of monotheism indeed as we
saw in the beginning
arabia was very much involved in the
wider political and
social context of the middle east at the
time
including the cultures of the two great
empires
by the fourth to fifth century there
existed many
different religious groups on the
arabian peninsula including many
jewish tribes as well as christians of
various
different denominations indeed the
razanids who were often vassals to the
byzantine empire
followed a monophysite christianity and
it is quite likely that there lived
christian groups further inside the
peninsula as well
even if they weren't as numerous as the
jews to a lesser degree but still
significant
there were also zoroastrians living in
arabia at the time so
we get the picture of a quite diverse
and complex religious milieu
so monotheism was actually quite common
in arabia at this time
but of course this could differ from
region to region and from
different cities for example it seems
that the
city of mecca was largely polytheistic
while the city of yathrib which later
became known as medina
housed a large amount of jewish
monotheistic communities
and the presence of monotheism in arabia
can also be seen very clearly in a lot
of the archaeological evidence that we
have
there even seems to have been
monotheistic communities in arabia that
were neither
jewish nor christian but who consider
themselves as belonging to a
primeval original monotheism of
abraham in the islamic tradition this
independent monotheistic community
or group is known as the hanifia
although there is less evidence for them
in the archaeological record
now looked at from a historical
perspective and putting aside
theological perspectives or narratives
we can see where some of these central
aspects of the later islamic religion
comes from including the name allah for
god
as well as other names the primary name
of god in islam
is allah the precise etymological
origins of the name has been debated but
the majority of scholars
i would say even muslims and non-muslims
agree that it is probably an abbreviated
form of
al-ilah meaning literally the god
illah being the arabic word for god or
divinity
and al being the definite article
and the archaeological record actually
supports this
we have inscriptions by a north arabian
christians in pre-islamic times
that refer to their god precisely as
al-ilah
and similarly in southern arabia what is
today yemen
there appears to have been a period of
monotheistic flourishing
either through the influence of judaism
and its adoption by the state or
through some independent form of
monotheism and in this
south arabian context the monotheistic
god was referred to as
now in the south arabian dialect the
definite article was not the prefix
al as in the northern equivalent or in
classical arabic
but rather the suffix an so
if we transpose the name to classical
arabic
this name for god becomes another one of
the most
primary names of god in islam and
moreover in this south arabian context
god was also very tellingly called
elahan
the abbreviated form allah appears to
have been the result of a certain arabic
dialect
in western or north western arabia
including perhaps the hijaz
but we do find examples of this
abbreviated form allah
in earlier evidence as well in the
nabataean kingdom of northern arabia we
find
examples of the name allah both as parts
of personal names like abdullah
and indeed abdullah was according to
tradition the name of the prophet
muhammad's own father
but we also see the name allah used
independently in various prayers and
rock carvings and the nabatae and script
even though it is quite rare there is
this inscription for example which
states
which translates to he made a burnt
offering and swore by allah who is
living
that he shall command with greatness but
the name allah is also sometimes invoked
alongside
other deities quotes and he placed it
under the protection of kahel
allah and uttar of the east from strong
and weak and purchase and pledge for all
time
so what does this mean well in the
islamic tradition there is often the
idea that the pre-islamic arabs
did worship allah but that they did so
alongside other lesser deities and that
this
is the origins of the concept of shirk
or of associating
partners with god the which is the
greatest sin in the islamic religion
many scholars today even argue that the
group referred to as the mushrikun in
the quran
usually translated as the polytheist
might
actually be referring to other
monotheistic groups that
nonetheless did not follow a monotheist
that was as
strict as that of the prophet muhammad
in any case what the archaeological
evidence shows is that the name allah
did exist as a name for god in ancient
times
some scholars including al-jalad argue
that the use of the word allah in the
polytheistic context
may have simply referred to the most
exalted god in a particular context
in any case it seems clear however that
the name derives from the title al-ilah
or
the god so commonly invoked by christian
inscriptions and in southern arabia as
well
many features that would later become so
important for the religion of islam
do appear in pre-islamic arabia in both
in
polytheistic and monotheistic contexts
we have maybe even found a example of
the bismillah
in a pre-islamic inscription in 2018
an inscription was found in the adali
region of yemen which seems to
either say taken transposing from south
arabian dialect into account
quote bismillahirrahmanirrahim assamwat
which would translate as in the name of
god
the merciful and compassionate lord of
the heavens
with the exception of the last part lord
of the heavens this is the formula that
starts
every quranic chapter of surah except
for
one and is a major aspect of the islamic
religion
however this is actually quite uncertain
the inscription may in fact instead say
quote
which would instead translate to in the
name of god the merciful
have mercy upon us lord of the heavens
and this would clearly echo the words of
the bible
in any case we are clearly dealing with
a monotheistic invocation here
one that makes sense in the context of
southern arabia at the time which had a
strong flourishing of monotheism
remember the name of god
or being used commonly in the region at
this time and reappearing in this
particular invocation
as well as being under christian rule at
the time of the inscriptions composition
so the inscription makes sense in a lot
of ways
we can see that arabia by the time of
the prophet muhammad
was a melting pot of various different
religious and intellectual traditions
while the polytheism or paganism was
probably the religion practiced by the
majority of the population
there were still very strong
monotheistic communities including
jewish groups christians as well as
maybe even
independent monotheistic groups like the
hanefia
that that's talked about in the islamic
station clearly then things
aren't as simple as the narrative that i
presented at the beginning
and we can perhaps begin to understand
the context
in which a prophet by the name of
muhammad would appear on the scene
and change world history i hope you
enjoyed this dive into ancient arabia
and its religious traditions
a lot of the material used here was
based on the works of the epigraphist
philologist and historian of language
ahmed al-jalad
whose works i highly recommend you check
out as always i will leave a list of
sources in the description
for those especially interested in the
languages and cultures of pre-islamic
arabia
i will also leave links to two very
important databases on the south
arabian and north arabian inscriptions
one is the digital archive for the study
of pre-islamic arabian inscriptions
and the other is oceana which is also a
database for for inscription so
you can find all of that in the
description as well and as always this
video is brought to you by our patrons
i'd like to give a special shout out to
our new saint abe
catbey thank you all so much again again
i can't stress this enough it is because
of you that i can keep making these
videos so thank you
if anyone else wants to become a patron
i will leave a link
to that stuff in the description so
thank you all for watching the video if
you want to support the channel you can
become a patreon and i will leave a link
to that in the comments and in the
description
and otherwise you can support us by only
just leaving a
like or a comment and of course by
subscribing to the channel
and i'll see you next time
[Music]